let's get to know Adam West I asked him
who his favorite Batman was let's take a
listen not really because you know
they're all doing their thing and
they're very talented people and I think
by the way that the new one Ben Affleck
will be very good he's a fine actor and
he'll bring something fresh in which is
what you have to
do does Adam West have a favorite
automobile well I'm partial to
Porsche uh and maybe a Ferrari or a good
American a good American muscle car
there are some wonderful
ones did you have a favorite comic book
hero yes Batman Batman was your hero so
you ended up playing your
hero isn't it unusual it's so odd did
that happen I mean you go along in life
and you never know what door is going to
open to to have read those comic books
in the old bunk house and then end up in
Hollywood playing Batman it's strikingly
um
unusual